I'm standing in the streets I see a
person being bullied I can do something
about it no no I don't want to ruin my
career because what if I save that lady
and then the cop comes and arrests me so
let him be to beat the wife up it's okay
I'm just gonna mind my own business
that's a coward in in a way right I
don't think tolerance is a virtue at all
actually it is certainly not a Christian
virtue if you look at the New Testament
you don't really see Christ saying it's
okay I'm just going to accept this no he
speaks his mind he makes a very clear
delineation between right and wrong god
of the Old Testament certainly not one
for tolerance so the idea that this is a
virtue something we should strive
towards I disagree and it's the same
thing with blanket Concepts like
diversity we're supposed to believe
tolerance is inherently good diversity
is inherently good just because but no
they've provided no moral framework as
to why those things should be something
we strive for we're supposed to just
accept it without question